cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
martial foucault bonjour merci d'être
sur ce plateau vous êtes directeur du
cevipof centre d'étude de la vie
politique française avec nous pour
analyser après une petite nuit les
résultats de ce premier tour des
élections législatives en france d'abord
la grande gagnante de ce scrutin martial
foucault l'abstention
52,49 % les français ne se sont jamais
aussi peu mobilisés pour élire leurs
députés est ce que le fait que les
enjeux de ces cinq cent soixante dix
sept scrutins locaux et été écrasé par
un duel nationale entre emmanuel macron
et la nuque baisse c'est une explication
une des explications de ce chiffre qu'on
va derrière vous il ya plusieurs
explications j'ai reprendre vos termes
parce qu'il est bon en fait je crois que
ceux qui a écrasé la mobilisation la
participation c'est l'enchaînement de
quatre élections à la fois les deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle et
l'a de nouveau les électeurs étaient
convoqués aux urnes et finalement on est
dans un système où l'élection
présidentielle a pris tellement de place
que aujourd'hui les électeurs
considèrent que les jeux sont faits à
l'issue de l'élection présidentielle les
remobiliser pour une élection initiative
qui est fondamental c'est à élire des
représentants qui vont fabriquer la loi
ne les a pas suffisamment mobilisé alors
est-ce que la campagne ya contribué oui
probablement on a vu qu'il ya une
accélération plus tôt à la fin de cette
campagne mais pendant tout le mois de
mai un seul le candidat à occuper
l'espace médiatique jean luc mélenchon
et cette alliance du ps donc évidemment
c'est un pro produits à la fois une
remobilisation du camp des gauches et
puis une forme d'attentisme de la part
des autres électeurs pour les autres
familles politiques
il y a quelque chose de paradoxal vous
venez de le dire parce qu'une partie des
français qui ne votent pas ne se sentent
pas ou peu entendu tout court et
reproche au président macron une forme
d'exercice solitaire voire autoritaire
du pouvoir or précisément l'assemblée
nationale est peut-être le lieu
d'expression de ces contre-pouvoirs ici
en france oui c'est une forme de
paradoxe est à la fois ont souvent dit
la france est un peuple politique
politisé or là avec ces chiffres d'une
faible participation et quand même une
érosion la participation depuis
maintenant trente ans on se demande si
le peuple français est encore un peu
plus politiques parce que l'occasion qui
est donné d'envoyer à l'assemblée
nationale leurs représentants ne l'est
je le dirai ne les incite pas davantage
que pour d'autres scrutins a participé
donc il y a une forme à la fois de gérer
deux de colère du peuple français qui
estime qu' aujourd'hui mm macro gouverne
comme un monarque et c'est souvent
l'expression qui employés et lorsque
l'occasion est donnée aux on le verra
dimanche prochain mais on risque même
d'assister à une forme de blocage
institutionnel avec une majorité
relative pour le président la république
qui provoque une forme d'inconnue dans
la manière dont l'exécutif va pouvoir
jouer avec le législatif voilà d'où ma
question suivante effectivement alors
comment la colère s'exprimera on en
reparlera peut-être après de la semaine
prochaine mais donc la coalition
présidentielle effectivement ensemble
obtient à peu près neuf points de moins
qu'en 2010 est corrigé moi ce que je me
trompe après la première élection des
manuels macron s'il ya donc majorité
relative qui est probable et ce qui ne
serait pas inédit dans l'histoire
politique française effectivement la
question c'est est-ce que cette
coalition va gouverner avec un coup de
barre à gauche un peu barre à droite en
fonction des cas où avec un choix
politique plus globale je rappellerai un
point parce que c'est important quand on
analyse on est une élection là on la
compare toujours à la précédente et
c'est vrai que la coalition du ps fait
un score aujourd'hui et ce matin très
important mais quand on y regarde
attentivement on observe que ce n'est
que la somme des composants herbe
de d'il ya cinq ans concernant le site
majorité relative se dessine ce qui est
fort probable aujourd'hui
on va assister à quelque chose de
totalement différent à 1988 parce que
cette année est souvent rappelée en dix
ans françois mitterrand d'ailleurs
n'avait pas appelé en 1988 à ce qu'un
seul parti gouverne donc plus celle
rocard s'était retrouvé premier ministre
avec une majorité relative et à l'époque
il avait utilisé sorte de droit tirage
infinie illimité de ce qu'on appelle le
49-3 cette manière de faire voter des
lois sans le débat au parlement je
rappelle un point il est important cet
instrument a profondément évolué depuis
30 ans aujourd'hui on n'a plus le droit
d'utiliser
chaque fois qu'on le souhaite ce 49 3
pour gouverner alors c'est à quelle
implication si la majorité relative le
gouvernement et peut-être elisabeth
board si elle reste première ministre va
devoir négocier pour chaque loi avec des
députés pour constituer une majorité
absolue pour faire passer les lois et
donc c'est un jeu on rentre dans un jeu
très parlementariste alors qu'on n'est
pas un régime parlementaire faire des
marchandises des arrangements avec
chacun des députés souvent de droite
peut-être parfois de gauche sur des
projets de loi sur le plus petit
dénominateur commun permettant à ce
gouvernement de mettre en place ce
programme d'où le risque de blocage oui
le risque de blocage parce qu'à chaque
fois il ya la menace d'un vote de
censure si une loi n'obtient les
suffrages nécessaires c'est à dire 2 189
députés alors en cas de majorité
relative à la majorité absolue ça se
joue à six sièges dimanche prochain
elles les républicains pour le coup
pourrait peut-être avoir un rôle de
pivot comme un lot de consolation après
des mauvais résultats ja oui alors oui
c'est vrai que le lr va être le groupe
qui pourrait faire ou défaire des
majorités absolues toutefois on entendre
certaines responsables ces responsables
politiques au sein des l'air indiqué que
leurs jeunes et pas de et d emmanuel
macron 1 pour gouverner au cours des
cinq prochaines années et d'autres
disent c'est peut-être l'occasion pour
cette famille politique qui ressort
quand même un petit peu abîmés
l'élection présidentielle de retrouver
deux à la fois une voie et de l'espace
au parlement je rappelle que le
parlement c'est l'occasion d'avoir des
tribunes nationale pour chacun des
députés llr pourrait être cette force ce
groupe d'appui à la majorité
présidentielle alors que penser
maintenant effectivement vous l'avez
évoqué delà du score de la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale la
nuque baisse elle fait jeu égal en
suffrages avec la coalition avec la
coalition présidentielle mais elle n'a
pas réussi son pari jean luc mélenchon
ne sera pas matignon oui ça pourrait
donner le sentiment d'une victoire au
goût d'inachevé parce que
on voit mal aujourd'hui dans la
configuration des second tour comment la
nuque ou la nuque baisse pourrait
obtenir une majorité absolue donc le
risque de cabine cohabitation est écarté
je remarque également que pour
la république en marche au sein de la
coalition ensemble il y à une perte de
sièges à prévoir une perte de voix par
rapport à 2017 et que au fond un parti a
largement progressé on en parle peu mais
c'est le rassemblement national qui
progresse fortement en voix et alors le
nombre de députés on ne peut pas le
connaître aujourd'hui mais il sera
largement plus important qu'il ne
l'était il ya cinq ans au point de
constituer un groupe parlementaire c'est
à dire 15 députés au minimum et puis
enfin l air et l'air va perdre peut-être
moins de sièges que on pouvait
l'anticiper après le faible score de
valérie pécresse à l'élection
présidentielle donc on a une assemblée
nationale qui va être fragmenté aucun
groupe probablement majoritaire
et ce qui nous ramène à une situation où
est ce que les français voulaient
finalement contrebalancer le pouvoir
donné à emmanuel macron il ya quelques
semaines élection présidentielle et se
dire que le la vie politique c'est une
vie où il ya des des controverses où il
ya des conflits et qu'on ne peut pas
donner à une seule personne et à un seul
gouvernement toutes les jets des relais
les degrés de liberté les marges de
manoeuvre pour gouverner ce pays et ce
qui peut amener à une situation vous
l'évoquez tout à l'heure peut-être pas
de blocage total mais peut-être eu un
rythme de réformes beaucoup plus faible
que si emmanuel macron avait eu les
mains libres avec une majorité absolue
pour revenir sur la nuque mais c'est
donc ce satisfecit hier soir de jean luc
mélenchon et vous le disiez tout à
l'heure si on additionne les résultats
au premier tour des législatives des
partis de gauche en 2017 en réalité même
je crois que la nuit passe aujourd'hui
fait moins que tous les partis de gauche
accumuler alors après le jeu de la règle
du scrutin qui est un peu compliquée
fait que un score quasiment égales pour
le coup en transformation de député ça
sera ça sera une percée mais met
toutefois en nombre de suffrages n'y a
pas de réelle avancée le bon nom vous
avez raison c'est important de regarder
un peu les bénéfices de cette coalition
le principal bénéfice sierre de la nuque
c'est la france insoumise la france est
soumise va placer probablement de 17
députés à une centaine les autres
composantes de cette coalition parti
communiste parti socialiste et europe
écologie les verts vont garder
sensiblement le même nombre de députés l
on pourrait se dire pour ses alliés
c'était la seule manière de préserver
une alors avec la tête exactement et
puis quand je regarde attentivement pour
le second tour ce sont près de deux cent
soixante douze duels qui opposeront
ensemble à nu baisse ce qui veut dire
que le paysage politique on a beaucoup
parlé d'une d'une sorte de tripartition
l'espace politique avec en marche
la france insoumise et le rassemblement
national pour cette élection initiative
c'est plus une bipolarisation parce que
ce sera vraiment jean luc mélenchon
contre emmanuel macron et on verra dans
cet entre-deux-tours de campagne si ces
deux acteurs vont se jeter immédiatement
dans l'affrontement d'une vision
totalement différente pour la société
est d'ailleurs pour le coup vous le
disiez marine le pen fait un bon score
par rapport à l'élection précédente mais
jean-luc mélenchon réussit à être le
deuxième homme d'une élection
législative alors qu'il était le
troisième de la présidentielle
absolument et ça c'est je crois que
c'est un point important parce que les
les duels qui vont opposer la nuque mais
ce rassemblement national sont passés
aussi important qu'on aurait pu
l'imaginer au soir de l'élection
présidentielle et est-ce qui a désiré
certaine manière provoqué une forme de
2,2
d'incompréhension sur les fameuses
consignes de vote quel et vous faire si
vous êtes opposé à un candidat qui n'y a
pas un candidat n'y a pas de consignes
nationales à la république en marche
pour voter comme ça a pu être le cas
pour la présidentielle ça promet des
jours compliqués voté en faveur d'un
candidat du ps un mot enfin de d'eric
zemmour la stratégie est de ne pas
s'allier à al eric zemmour du côté de la
2de marine le pen a priori à payer est
battu à dès le premier tour dans le var
est-ce que c'est l'échec du truck bismes
à la française qui a un avenir politique
aujourd'hui en france pour les idées
d'eric zemmour
c'est une c'est une fin de parcours
assez difficile parce que au-delà d'eric
zemmour mêmes députés sortants comme
guillaume pelletier dans le loir-et-cher
n'appelle ne sera pas ne sera pas élu
donc
est-ce qu'il ya encore de la place pour
les idées portées par eric zemmour sa
stratégie de ne pas faire alliance avec
le rassemblement national lui a
probablement coûté la possibilité
d'entrer au parlement ça c'est le
premier élément puis il ya une deuxième
gérer qu'il ya une deuxième inconnue
aujourd'hui c'est près de 130 mille
militants autour de reconquête est ce
que eric zemmour a envie après deux
échecs de continuer lui qui a une forme
2d d'adolescence politiques n'ayant pas
un long parcours dans la vie politique
et la gestion des partis des
organisations est ce qu'il aura envie
personnellement de se lancer dans une
reconstruction n'oublions pas que la
prochaine élection en france alors c'est
une élection européenne il faudra
attendre 2026 pour des élections locales
en france est ce qu il veut consacrer
tout ce temps c'est très long quatre ans
a organisé structuré faire révélé des
personnalités au sein de cette famille
politique je crois que
à différents égards mais cela me fait
rappeler quand même le parcours de jean
pierre chevènement en 2002 on promettait
parfois un destin beaucoup plus
important qui n'a pu obtenir est très
très vite sa famille politique s'est
disloqué donc eric zemmour va devoir
être confrontés et lutter contre ce ce
cheminement assez classique des familles
politiques émergent subitement mais qui
peuvent disparaître encore plus
rapidement mais des questions aussi sur
le traitement médiatique dont il a
bénéficié en tout cas dont il a été
l'objet cette cet automne merci
infiniment martial foucault d'être venu
ce matin sur le plateau de paray directe
me donner ces quelques pistes de
réflexion donc après ce premier tour
second tour dimanche à prendre les vans
les français sauf surprise ne voteront
plus pendant quatre ans vous l'avez dit
merci encore on se retrouve juste après
la pause avec damien coq